der alltag im weltraum ist ziemlich
unkomfortabel und ganz schön
kompliziert zu essen gibt es
ausschließlich gefriergetrocknete
gerichte sich den rücken zu kratzen ist
schier unmöglich und wie frustriert
muss man bitte sein wenn man gerade in
den ausschüssen braucht aber der
kollege ihn an bord in eine dunkle ecke
der station hat entscheiden lassen
die nasa tüftelt tatsächlich gerade an
der lösung für all diese probleme und
die heißt 3d druck im weltraum was
genau astronauten und astronautinnen
bereits im all gedruckt haben und ob
demnächst ganze mondstation 3d gedruckt
werden jetzt in kriegs und science
fiction herzlich willkommen ach ja und
am schluss habe ich noch ein geschenk
für euch wir alle wissen von
urlaubsreisen dass es super nervig ist
wichtige dinge zu hause vergessen zu
haben
je nachdem wo wir im urlaub sind können
wir das dann aber am reiseort selbst
nachkaufen bei astronauten und
astronautinnen ist das anders wenn ihnen
dinge verloren gehen oder sachen im
weltraum ausgehen sieht sie zu 100
prozent abhängig von der nächsten
lieferung die sie von der erde erreicht
und das kann dauern mal eben schnell
shoppen im weltall ist eben nicht und
selbst die dinge die man mitnehmen darf
können an einer hand abgezählt werden
denn daran dass es extrem aufwändig ist
dinge ins all zu bringen hat sich nichts
geändert seitdem es die bemannte
raumfahrt überhaupt gibt je nachdem wie
weit die jeweilige mission von der erde
entfernt es ist es auch oft überhaupt
gar nicht möglich etwas nachzuliefern
teilweise mussten auch erst passende
transportmöglichkeiten geschaffen
werden
da sind dann auch schon mal jahre bei
vergangen die nasa sucht händeringend
nach neuen lösungsansätzen für all
diese probleme und hier kamen die
technik des 3d drucks ganz zurecht hier
bei uns auf der erde kann man mit hilfe
von 3 d drucker mittlerweile
medizinischen prothesen anfertigen und
überhaupt die kompliziertesten teile
jeder art nachbauen viele sagen der
technik das potenzial voraus ganze
industriezweige zu revolutionieren und
auch im weltraum eröffnet der 3d druck
tatsächlich unbegrenzte möglichkeiten
es würde die arbeit der astronauten
unheimlich erleichtern druck dateien
könnten auf der erde erstellt und per e
mail an das raumschiff gesendet werden
kleine satelliten komponenten könnten
genauso wie komplette experimente dann
vor ort gedruckt und die
direkt verwendet werden wow was für
eine vorstellung und tatsächlich
arbeiten weltraumbehörden weltweit
daran um diese idee zur realität werden
zu lassen auf der internationalen
raumstation iss hat einen 3d drucker
auch schon seine erste testphase
erfolgreichen das ich gemacht insgesamt
13 teile hat er produziert unter anderem
einen raatschen schlüssel mehr als elf
zentimeter lang innerhalb von einer
woche wurde er auf der erde designt von
der sicherheitsregeln der nasa
abgesegnet und ist dann zum ss drucker
geschickt worden um das werkzeug in 3d
zu drucken hat es nicht länger als vier
stunden gedauert wahnsinn wirklich in
gebrauch war der 3d schlüssel dann im
weltraum allerdings nicht denn die nasa
ingenieure haben andere dinge mit ihm
vor auf der erde wollen sie nun
erforschen wie sich die geschmolzenen
plastik tröpfchen in der
schwerelosigkeit zu objekt schichten
verbinden eindrucksvoll hätten die 13 0
gedruckten objekte gezeigt wie stabil
und filigranen dinge werden können die
in der schwerelosigkeit gedruckt worden
waren so die nasa wenn es gibt einen
großen unterschied zum 3d druck auf der
erde im weltraum übernimmt die
oberflächenspannung die aufgabe die
winzigen plastik tröpfchen an ort und
stelle zu halten
aus denen die gedruckten objekte am ende
bestehen dass er möglichst ganz andere
objekte zu drucken als hier auf der erde
denn hier geschieht das durch die
gravitation nicht nur die nasa sondern
auch die esa also die europäische
raumfahrtagentur plan große erfolge in
sachen 3d druck die unterkünfte für
eine geplante mondbasis sollen aus staub
gedruckt werden und auch wenn es völlig
abgefahren klingt diese pläne könnten
tatsächlich aufgehen
hoffnung macht ein erster versuch in
einem ingenieursteam eine 1,5 tonnen
schweren baustein hergestellt hat und
zwar aus basalt also vulkanischen
gestein das mondstaub zu 99,8 prozent
ähnlich ist und flüssiger tinte und
auch das essence probleme im weltall
könnte mit hilfe der 3d technik
vergessen sein
die nasa konkurriert mit einem
dienstleister die grundelemente des
essens also proteine und kohlehydrate
beispielsweise in langlebiges pulver
zelle einen 3d drucker könnte das
lieblingsgericht der kuh dann auf einer
heißen platte schicht für schicht
anrichten
in ein paar jahren könnten es sich die
astronauten also eventuell
mit den entsprechenden aromen frisch
gedruckt schmecken lassen
eine rosige zukunft für den weltraum
vielen dank an technology review in
zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion ist
dieses video entstanden und exklusiv
für pixum zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein
geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich eine
ausgabe dieser wirklich
außergewöhnlichen zeitschrift gratis
wenn ihr auf diesen link klingt es lohnt
sich wirklich und hier geht es weiter
mit virtual reality verändert die welt
genauso welt verändern wie 3d druck
klick drauf wenn es euch interessiert
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran